- All right, Darnetta.
- Yes.
- Darnetta, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I was born in Oakland, California,
but I've been here in
Los Angeles ever since
I was two years old.
- Okay. And tell me about your family.
You grew up with both your parents?
- Until I was 10 years old.
At the time when I was 10,
I was molested by my father.
First time I had sex I got pregnant
so I came downtown to the
St Anne's maternity home
over in the Everardo area.
Stayed there.
- What age was this?
- I was 10.
- You were pregnant at 10?
- Yes.
- Jesus.
- First time I had sex I got
pregnant, it was by my dad.
I stayed there for
about six weeks and then
I agreed to have an abortion
to go home, back home.
At the time we were living
in Compton, California.
I stayed at home, maybe for about a year
then I started running away from home.
I was in and out of McLaren
hall, different foster homes.
I was in like 14, 15 foster homes.
- Did the sexual abuse
with your dad continue?
- Yes, I only had sex with
my father until I was, what?
19, 20 years old.
I'd never had another man.
I had my daughter at 16, which
is also my little sister.
I had her by my father.
I have two children now.
When I was 21, I had another,
well, seven years later I
had another child, a boy.
I've been downtown ever since 1984.
The beginning of 84, like
the first of the year.
When I first moved down here, I moved into
where the st Mark's is the 611,
the woman and children's shelter.
I've been downtown ever since.
I was homeless 20 years.
Down here I just got my housing
about maybe three years ago.
Permanent housing.
I was a transit down here on the street,
in the tents and you know,
I lived in every last one of
these hotels, downtown area.
I don't have a really
bad criminal background.
I have a couple of drug sales, you know.
- So let's back up to your parents.
So did your dad ever do any prison time
for what he did to you?
- No. My mother kept
him, so I mean, you know,
it was just something that, you know,
she chose to say it was my fault.
Something about it was my fault.
- At 10 years old.
- Yeah, well, I was womanish, I was fast
and I enticed him or whatever.
I mean, between that
and her trying to refuse
that it was even happening at all.
She knew it was happening
because she knew I was pregnant.
- Yeah, that's a pretty good sign,
- So I had my baby, I
went back home with my mom
and I stayed there for
about like six months.
We were living in Carson then.
I, you know, had both of my kids with me
till my daughter was like maybe 10.
Till '84 when I had my son, in '83.
I came downtown, I applied for GR,
I came downtown, they put me at the 611.
And I've been downtown ever since.
- So your kids were raised by you?
- They were raised by me,
my daughter stayed with
me until she was 10
then she stayed with my mom.
My son was raised by my boyfriend.
I only had one boyfriend
all through school.
And so my son was raised by him.
(cell phone rings)
That's my phone.
- That's your phone.
So your daughter went with your mom,
was your dad still in the picture?
- Well, he was still alive, you know.
Him and my mom weren't together, but yeah.
She went in with my mom.
I mean it was like preferable
to her going into foster care.
I had been in foster care,
so I didn't want her to go in foster care.
I gave her to my mom to, you
know, she wanted my daughter.
- And you were on the streets so.
- And she didn't want my baby.
So I was in the streets
of Long Beach for a while.
And then I came downtown,
like on a fluke with,
a friend of mine came
down to apply for GR.
And I applied, the only
time I've ever been on GR.
- So you have a son as well?
- I have a son as well, he's 35.
36, actually, he'll be 36 next month.
- So you raised him?
- No, he was raised, when he was three,
well I had them both till
she was 10 and he was three.
That's when I came downtown.
And when I came down--
- Where'd your son go?
- My son was raised by
one of my boyfriends.
He, you know, was there
when my son was born.
- He wasn't the father, but--
- No, he wasn't the father.
That's one of the problems that I have
with my son right now.
'Cause my son is mixed
with Mexican and black,
so Greg, big difference.
But he was my boyfriend for
all the time I was in junior high school.
My first boyfriend other than my dad.
So he raised my son.
He came to the County
building, he got my son
and he raised him until he was grown.
I recently been back in my son's life,
maybe about a year and a half.
And he came down, he found me,
actually right before he had his son.
Right when he had his
son, and his son is seven.
So he's been back in my life
like seven years, my son.
My daughter, she lives in Antelope Valley.
She just recently found out
within the last seven years
about me and her having the same father.
You know, she really didn't know.
She had, you know, thoughts about it,
but she didn't really know the truth.
- Yeah.
- Like I said, I've
been a transit down here
for the last, going on 30 years.
- Do you say--
- I just recently
acquired permanent housing.
I live in the Alexander hotel right now.
- Do you use any of the drugs
that are on the street here?
- Yeah, I was an addict.
I was a crack addict, you
know, for the last 20 years.
I started using crack
when I was about maybe,
after my son was born.
And basically I've been a crack addict.
You know, I've been in
recovery for the last year
trying to get my life together.
I have relapse problems, but (laughs)
- What do you do for money now?
- I finally have an income after 20 years
of being here with no income at all.
I'm on disability, SSI disability.
- Until you got that, how
were you supporting yourself?
- That's how I support myself.
- No, but before that.
- Before that, crack
sales, I sold enough dope,
I was a worker.
I sold enough dope to pay my, you know,
buy me a outfit every day.
You know, eat, pay my rent.
Because I lived in all of these hotels
before they turned SRO.
I was paying by the day 20, 30.
I mean, $50, $60 a day.
So I made enough money, you know.
I have five sales cases now
and other cases that I have are
me having my own sack.
I was just, I never was a baller,
I just was a worker.
- Yeah.
- I still have problems every now and then
with my, you know, with my addiction.
Finding something to replace
the addiction is the problem.
- Do you still have
contact with your family?
- My two children, I'm the
only one left of my family.
It's me and my two kids.
Yes, I still have contact with them. Yeah.
My son, he was in prison.
He did seven years for abuse.
He has problems with women,
mostly it's my fault.
Because I was the crack head
that he heard about all his life.
He was just like your mom,
she's a crack head on skid row.
That's all he ever heard all his life.
So he has mental problems, you know,
I guess insanity runs
in our family (laughs)
but yeah, dysfunction.
- Yeah, that's a common story down here.
Do you think if your
childhood had been different
that your life might've led
you down a different path?
- I'm pretty sure.
- Yeah.
- Would you say
your parents were the--
- My mom was a groupie, you know,
she was the definition
of a groupie, you know,
up North she was part
of the Pather family.
They were groupies.
You know, my auntie has a
son by Johnny guitar Watson,
you know, the music field,
you know, she was a groupie.
(laughs)
They used to drop pills and
go to concerts and you know,
me and my cousin, they
had to take us with them.
So, you know, we grew up together.
She, you know, my dad, he was security.
He worked at the Federal
Reserve Bank of San Francisco
right here on Olympic
and Grant for 35 years,
he retired from there.
He's dead now.
But if he was alive, I mean basically,
all of my relationships are dysfunctional
based on my dysfunctional beginnings.
You know, I was married for five years.
I'm just recently divorced.
All of my relationships are
dysfunctional based on it.
So yes, I believe if my
beginnings were different,
I would have had a different outcome.
- Different role models.
- Different, yeah.
- A little more--
- I was, you know, everything
that was right was wrong
and everything that was wrong was right.
I mean, that's the way it
has always been with me.
You know, starting with my dad.
I mean all of the tears for healing,
all of the things, you know,
me knowing it wasn't my fault.
I was a child who, you know,
of molestation and all of that.
It really didn't pan out with me because
I was in love with my father.
My father was my everything.
He did everything for me, you know.
That was the only thing that was wrong.
And so, you know, all my
relationships are dysfunctional
because of that.
You know, I believe if
I'm not getting paid
or whatever for it,
so that made me have a
dysfunctional marriage.
You know, I had issues because of that.
- Yeah.
- You know, basically that's where I'm at
and I'm still downtown.
(laughs)
- All right, Darnetta.
Well, thank you so much for talking to me
and sharing your story.
Good luck with everything.